that's thursday and you know what uh
thursdays mean it's time to break down
everything survivor 42. yeah and last
night's episode saw the castaways hungry
exhausted and paranoid we also got to
see another advantage come into play and
despite it being a season 41 copycat the
game switched it up slightly by adding a
colorful twist
at the challenge i got an advantage and
i've been hoping that there would be a
chance when i get to camp that i'll be
able to read it and actually be what it
is
congratulations you have a clue to a
secret event that can offer you power in
the game it's hidden five places from
your water wall under a coconut you must
move quickly and cover your tracks or
your recipe and caught with homework
this is why then i just says beware five
pieces away from the crocodile
i know that the only chance i have to do
this is now
because everyone goes to the water well
to talk
so i go to the water well and i'm like
counting out five tastes one way one two
three four five
i start flipping over coconuts and i
don't see anything
so i turn around
and i see that there's one coconut
that's spread open
and i'm like if it's close to five paces
i think that might be it
so i reach down open it up
and it's just like
this hall and i'm like what's in this
hole
oh my god
[Music]
so i put my hand in and i pull out this
container covered and surprised
why am i red i kind of get the point of
the advantage where it says caught
red-handed because it's going to be all
over your hand
and now of course we're joined by our
one and only survivor correspondent
season 41 winner erica hey erica we have
so much to talk about thank you hi i'm
excited to get into it let's do it okay
so let's just get right into it we need
to know what would you do if you were
literally caught red-handed with an
advantage like drea
i feel like it depends on who you're
talking to but i feel like my default
would be ew oh my god what is this am i
bleeding can you look at this did
something happen and i feel like i would
have whoever is talking to me join me in
figuring out what it is what would you
guys do same thing i would say i hit a
rock i'm bleeding 100 but how does she
miss that spot she cleaned her whole
head the entire it doesn't make sense to
me there's something fishy about the
whole situation but she dipped her hand
in all the water and there was that one
spot that was left i don't know there's
something wrong there andrea now holds
four advantages to her name how do you
think should she should go ahead with
this because it's it's really
interesting at this point because she
has all the power
she has a lot of advantages i almost
feel like there are too many advantages
but that's a whole other conversation
but i have witnessed people have
advantages and get a bit too comfortable
and i think that it's impressive drea
has all these advantages but now it's a
matter of seeing is she going to be able
to play them to be able to move herself
forward in the game so we will see do
you think so do you think she's going to
do well with it i think she'll probably
be able to play one or two really well
but i i think playing four out of four
is a lot to ask one more question
because that advantage she has she can
find out who else has the idols
yeah she knows marianne has it she knows
marianne has it she knows mike has it
she knows where the other amulets are
she has a lot going for her she's going
to make it good you are intense yeah i
mean i
last night okay so last night we did see
marianne's emotional plea at the
immunity challenge for her tribe mates
to take jeff's rice offer we also saw
romeo's extreme paranoia to the point
where i mean he caused
minute chaos before tribal after
irritating high so how mentally draining
is the game from your experience erica
like what are these castaways going
through on days 16 and 17. i mean
survivor is hard because there are
people lying to you telling you the
truth everyone's playing their own game
they're saying they're looking out for
you and that's hard to deal with in
general but then when you're not eating
and you're not sleeping it is rough
there were moments in the game where i
remember i would be thinking something
and then saying something and what i
would say was not what i was thinking in
my head and i'm thinking what is going
on
i feel so bad because people truly go
crazy out there omar lost a lot of
weight in last last night when i was
watching it i mean they're going through
something right now yeah yesterday's
tribal council was also a critical
moment in the game as the castaway sent
packing would become the first member of
the jury yeah and sadly we saw chanel
get voted out and her torch snuffed by
jeff and boyce she was not no impressed
so erica were you surprised that chanel
became the first member of the jury
sadly i wasn't surprised about this okay
i think that chanel's a huge fan chanel
really thinks about the game logically
like if this vote goes here where are
the other votes going to go thinking
about the numbers and i think that the
focus on strategy she might have missed
you know the human and social part of it
but i did talk to her today and she
knows that she made some mistakes and
she knows that she is very strategy
focused
well now you get to eat you're on the
jury so as a jury member now what are
you looking for in the game play as you
watch it
yeah so for me like i am like a
strategist person like i am someone who
loves and respects the game so much so i
want to see like
strategy i want to see that you like
very methodically chose to make this
move because you knew that three steps
down it was gonna
impact you know x y and z and so i'm a
strategist i want to see strategists
um you know i'm a very logical person so
like i obviously would naturally lean
more to like very logical uh clear like
shadow just type of people but like
honestly it's just like who is the best
game like who goes out there who gives
it their all and like ultimately like
who played the best
well with those many advantages still in
the game i hope she gets the gameplay
that she's looking for all right well
thank you so much erica for joining us
today to walk us through everything that
went on last night i mean we're calling
it a chaotic episode right
always a pleasure having you here
thank you guys for having me and of
course i'll be back next week to break
down everything and it should be a
dramatic double tribal council no who do
you think is going to win it at this
point at this point
it has to be it has to be one of the
canadians it has to be omar